si estás viendo una película y alguien
está haciendo matemáticas elegantes en
un pizarrón casi siempre veremos un
símbolo como este verdad y este símbolo
nosotros lo conocemos como radical
y esencialmente representa a la raíz
cuadrada y de hecho veremos otro tipo de
raíces en otros vídeos pero quizás tu
pregunta real en estos momentos sea qué
significa este símbolo y ahora que ya
hemos visto exponente veremos que no es
tan difícil de entender vamos a empezar
con un ejemplo muy bien digamos que
tenemos nosotros el número tres y
nosotros sabemos que si elevamos al
cuadrado el número 3
esencialmente esto nos da 9 verdad es
decir cuánto nos va a multiplicar 3
consigo mismo
2 veces 3 consigo mismo 2 veces esto nos
da 9 verdad entonces uno también podría
empezar al revés qué número multiplicado
por sí mismo
9 verdad y nosotros ya sabemos que el
resultado es 3 pero qué símbolo
podríamos utilizar para esto bueno pues
esencialmente para eso es que sirve el
símbolo del radical o calcular raíces
cuadradas esto nos dice que el número
multiplicado consigo mismo nos da 9 es
decir cuál es la raíz cuadrada de 9 y
nosotros ya sabemos que el resultado es
3 muy bien y por supuesto esto lo
podríamos repetir varias veces verdad
por ejemplo qué pasaría si nosotros
tenemos 4 al cuadrado si nosotros
queremos calcular 4 elevado al valer al
exponente 2 esto esencialmente nos dice
calcular 4 x 4 que es 16 y podríamos
empezar al revés verdad cuál sería la
raíz cuadrada de 16 es decir qué número
multiplicado consigo mismo dos veces
16 y eso es 4 verdad pero podríamos
también incluso empezar con los expone
con la raíz cuadrada verdad por ejemplo
qué tal si tenemos calcular tenemos que
calcular la raíz cuadrada de 25 entonces
nos preguntamos qué número multiplicado
consigo mismo dos veces nos da 25 y
nosotros sabemos que es 5 verdad porque
5 al cuadrado es decir 5 por 5 nos da 25
ok y quizás algunos de ustedes ya
empiecen a ver algo extraño verdad
porque si nosotros consideramos por
ejemplo menos 3 y el menos 3 lo elevamos
al cuadrado esto también nos vuelve a
dar 9 verdad menos 3 x menos 3 también
es 9
y lo mismo podríamos decir por ejemplo
para menos 4 porque menos 4 al cuadrado
también es 16 y menos 5 al cuadrado
también es 25 verdad por eso es que
nosotros decimos que esto de aquí es la
raíz que la raíz principal o la raíz
cuadrada la raíz cuadrada principal
principal verdad es decir a pesar de que
tenemos dos opciones tres y menos tres
solo estamos considerando la raíz
cuadrada principal es decir la parte
positiva verdad solo estamos
considerando la solución positiva
y de hecho sería interesante ver también
esta propiedad por ejemplo qué pasaría
si consideramos no la la raíz principal
de 9 sino su parte negativa verdad por
ejemplo esto podríamos elevarlo al
cuadrado y esto nos quedaría bueno por
nosotros sabemos que menos la raíz
cuadrada de 9 sería menos 3 verdad y eso
sería elevarlo al cuadrado entonces
cualquier número elevado al cuadrado
simplemente es siempre positivo verdad y
la raíz cuadrada de 9 al cuadrado es 9
por otro lado menos 3 al cuadrado
también es 9 entonces verificamos que
esta igualdad se cumple verdad pero de
hecho podríamos intentar hacer esto un
poquito más algebraico si nosotros
tenemos la raíz cuadrada de 9 y este es
un número desconocido
es en realidad nosotros sabemos que ese
número es 3 verdad pero por otro lado si
nosotros tuviéramos que x cuadrada fuera
9 pues aquí no tenemos una única
solución verdad en realidad tenemos dos
oportunidades tenemos que x podría ser 3
o bien que x podría ser menos 3 entonces
calcular la raíz cuadrada de 9 o
encontrar un número que elevado al
cuadrado nos dé 9 es casi equivalente
verdad sólo que ésta tiene una única
solución porque aquí sólo consideramos
la raíz principal mientras que aquí
podríamos tener dos soluciones x puede
ser 3 o x puede ser menos 3 si nosotros
quisiéramos hacer algo más equivalente
tendríamos que calcular más o menos la
raíz cuadrada de 9 y decir que este
número es x